this is a production of Cornell
University
again my name is Lorenzo cappelletti I'm
a farmer in incentive Italy this is part
of the landscape that I can look at from
my place which is not a bad landscape at
all that is but is somewhat challenging
in a values of in a number of ways again
we are based in a little town is called
to scania which is about 50 miles north
from Rome to scania is not in Tuscany
today but used to be about the same
thing about 2800 years ago then some
type of accident happen but anyway again
this is this is where we are this is
like a channel like be clickable say
that it's all a bulk anak bridge and
we'll just at the edge of it just with
the volcanic soils and into on to dub
pleo sonic clays below we have 125 acres
of total so first a very different
topography though again you can see here
all all of this it is all cliffs where
the lava come to an end so our soil is
very different from the top part of the
farm to the bottom part of the farm
which is good of course because
diversity is always good but it's also
challenging in the sense because you
know sometimes you want to deal with
just what you know and the more you have
in the more you have to know but but
that's good this is the other side of
the landscape that we have again this is
looking out of the edge with that main
house is the ballet we have a little
river stream of water that is permanent
but we don't pump any water out of it
because it's so overexploited we are
trying to be sustainable if we can but
again this is to show how our topography
sometimes is very peculiar we have all
this type of clips that are very
vertical and you can see the tufa rock
that is a volcanic
Rock volcanic type information that is
very light and very polar sand is
retaining a lot of water but it ends
abruptly with this cliffs and all these
cliffs have been worked out in the
passing centuries by mankind to the
point that we have this single standing
rock that I that this is all that
remains of a cliff that was there that
was completely hollowed out either to
come out materials for building or for
any other kind of purposes that we can
think of like this is again on the farm
sorry about this this is a little short
/ open-air cave this is man-made this
was carved by the Etruscans that is a
pre human civilization that was using
our ground let's say like that some 20
28 to 27 to 2,600 years ago basically
this was called out in order to let I
don't go by the Etruscan we're very
peculiar in and very good at modifying
the topography especially for having
results go by and this is the oh thank
you the the track of an ancient road
that was part of a system of it all that
later became one of the first girl to
ever be paved by the Romans now it's not
that everybody in this word has
something like that in on his farm you
know and and yeah I know it sounds sexy
but it's not that easy sometimes when
you have to deal with it you know one
one of the tombs these are gates dug by
the same people the seventh and the
sixth century BC was kind of the peak of
the Etruscan civilization in our in our
region and they used to dig all these
are underground cavities to use as gauge
that they wanted to look like houses and
they were decorated as houses and and
this is the main legacy that we have of
them because their actual houses were
built in mud and and and
and would so we have very little left of
it while we have this nice underground
cavity this is all on the farm this is a
column volume this was this used to be a
deposit of similarity earns so they were
buying the people or they were
insinuating them that is kind of funny
you look at all these peak marks you
know you can still see today what the
people have been working on and this is
that's the same but but but you can you
can have those peak marks that go for
miles all all around and this is a part
of the archeology map of the farm this
is the northern part of the farm we saw
this is the little road track that I
show you we have another one that is
bigger one this is the one that was
actually paved we have here the paving
stones that are still on site and each
of these dots is meaning something each
of these dots is one ruin that has been
there you know for a few thousands of
years again the most of all most of the
tools with installed by 76 century BC
but then in the middle age all of those
will use as houses so has been a
continuous flow history basically that I
feel on me while farming this piece of
land and this is one of the most
according to me most interesting
features that we have so up there is one
little too but down here this is the
entrance to a water tunnel there was
again dug by the same people about the
same time of course it's hard to exactly
tell when but we can say for sure that
if speedo man we can ship we can
probably date it to the same time frame
you know i will say 8th century BC
though it's it's more a matter of
picturing a time frame between the
eleventh and the 7th century BC that's
when the Etruscan civilization converted
a wide set of marshes and wood that was
central Italy into one of the most
sophisticated cultural system of all
times the farming system was I mean it
closer to what was you know maybe a
hundred years ago then what it is what
we're doing now is to what we were doing
a hundred years ago and this is
something that has stuck me but a long
story short these are water tunnels that
are cut directly into the bedrock I had
luck a few years ago to be participating
in with a group of experts that were
studying the same type of devices in
different 12 different countries across
the Mediterranean Middle East so it was
very interesting for me to start from
something that I have out on the farm
and be able to compare with what people
have and what people are doing in other
parts of the world a long story short
these are underground cavities that are
man-made they're creating a cavity so is
a depression into into the bedrock that
connecting to the internet work mainly
around the word are used for water
collection especially night countries in
in in in our geology is they serve the
multi-purpose surfaces is water
collection but is also a land reclaiming
from atop diversion of water from the
streams and they use the the Etruscan
they used it to modify a lot the
geography of the of the of the of the
terrain this is a Planning section of an
ideal cannot which is basically the same
type of devices we are talking about
that so horizontal tunnel and the ground
terminal that is directing to the
bedrock with walls that are lined and
let the water seep in or out of the
tunnel into the into the into the
bedrock and then a number of shafts that
are connecting the tunnel to the to the
to the surface I think this is quite the
whole thing is quite interesting this is
this is a passive system of course so
the water is collected from the
underground into the tunnel and it
automatically flows naturally flows onto
the surface so there is water coming up
to the surface available for human
activity that wouldn't be there whether
it not for the people who had dug this
type of devices even more interesting
is the fact and I was in the beginning
you know what I was kind of giving it
for granted when we bought the farm 20
years ago the guy we bought the farm
from he took me there say you know if
you don't periodically go in there and
do some maintenance this thing will clog
up and what it wouldn't come out of it
anymore I said okay you know one more
task to do but then if you think of it
if you think of it is not but now that
water is coming out of something that
was carved almost 8,000 years ago that
is sustainable and by going into and
doing some repair work I'm the last one
who joined the club there is a club who
started 2800 years ago so that's again
that's not the now and and why is the
water coming out of it because this is
sustainable water collected collecting
it's sustainable cares is passive so it
will never be over exploiting the
resource is sustainable because there
are multiple multiplicity of factors
that are coming in action you know to
make this water available that is what a
condensation what a collection from the
bedrock and all that kind of stuff again
in a cross section of a canal you can
see that there is a exchange of water
between the underground and and the and
the inside of tunnel that goes both ways
so sometimes water is draining into or
sometimes the water is draining out of
it and replenishing the water table and
this is particularly important in our
geology when we have multiplicity of
strata that are you know superimpose to
one another because our volcanic
activity went on for a number of about a
million years and but this is also quite
important for contrasting the effect of
climate change in our climate kind of
changes concentrating water fall more
and more in two peaks and alternating
with droughts and our soil is very
porous our bedrock is able to retain
about one-third of our rainfall so we
can weaken the Jutras can actually use
that in order to infiltrate tidal flow
into the underground then we'll be able
to be used again in the past in the
future and like a later time
mmm this is the this is the map of the
tunnel that we have we it's actually
getting the egg 08 is aligned with the
church actually is the church to be
aligned with the exit of the tunnel
since the time that was there for it mmm
there's a meaning of the churches that
again this type of devices are in water
producing so you walk into the tunnel
all the length of the carload you don't
see a screen you don't see the water
coming in but you see water coming out
which is pretty magic that's why it has
always been associated with a physical
thing well I did a study there are a
number of those around our area this is
this is the one this is the farm this is
the natural Conservancy of two scania
again very different geology this is the
study that we did around the tunnel in
order to understand and actually
determine that the water tunnel is not
hitting the water table so that water is
sustainable even because it's not part
of a common I mean is uh is there issues
that is shared it is very limited in
regard to the community who is using it
and is related to a very limited portion
of land that's why the water tunnel that
what the water that is coming out of the
water tunnel is is unpolluted while we
caught plenty of nitrates in this one
okay because this is a much master
resource you know but but the bastard
issues in the mastery of the community
who is using it and the more likely
there would be tensions you know so this
is not the case for the water tunnel and
and again I'm happy to do maintenance
this is a friend of mine actually from
New York City who is helping me out
sometime and it's good to know that the
club who started with the etruscan 2,500
years ago can analyst people that are
willing to be part of it and so we are
still having water today and also this
is this is not on the farm this is Lake
vehicle but it's just to remind how the
Etruscans were able it managing the
territory this lake has a an artificial
emissary which is underground which is a
tunnel which is giving water to
the city of Vinci Leone that was cut
basically to lower the level of the lake
so that all these northern parts of the
clay that could be put in into
cultivation the Etruscan did this in a
number of different cases and it's kind
of extraordinary to think of what they
did in terms of again creating called
arable land cultivated land and also
this is not the legacy of the Etruscans
maybe not everybody knows but it's them
who started to select out of a cardoon
an artichoke so this is in my garden and
I'm happy to have in my garden something
that is going that is keeping going the
race it's still a legacy of that land
not because of the topography of the
land but because of the people who used
to live there at the same time these are
some of my olive trees these are some of
the younger guys and these are out of my
of my place and this is also a legacy of
the Etruscans because they still the
Etruscans that by converting you know
all that into an agricultural system
they started the cultivation of olive
tree in central Italy and this is a very
important concept for me especially
speaking with olive tree you might
wonder why you know is the olive tree
that is quoted 76 time in the Old
Testament long and it's not a plum and
you might you might wonder why it's two
branches of auditory that is into the
log of the United Nation and it's not
just you know a palm well the reason is
that all the tree is of all cultivated
plants is the one that has the longest
lifespan it can stay there and produce
for a thousand years and when you
planting something like this the first
time you want to be well settled you
don't want to be a nomadic gathering
anymore you want to be settled in a
society that is giving you the power to
defend your work if push come to shop
which means that you planting something
that is going to stay there you want to
be identified in society so family names
and private names concept like property
property of land a structured society
with somebody to refer to if you're in
trouble
structured society means that of course
the that community is able to farm in a
way that is creating a surplus or it
wouldn't be possible to have a structure
society but the structure society is
also implying differentiated
architecture and so we end up with the
city but also writing these are all
features of what we call the urban
revolution of the etruscan between 11
and the 7th century BC they introduced
all of these elements including the
olive tree and including the water
tunnel these are all part of a big
picture in which is impossible to
determine the relation between cause and
effect but it's amazing to see how they
were able to put all this in action and
how r we're still dealing with with the
legacy of this again all the tree leaves
so long if you look at this tweak this
is another peculiarity of the auditory
the olive tree has but even in grown-up
parts of the plant and it's the only
plan that can survive being chopped off
the ground and transplanted even when
it's big but this also has a different
meaning because if you let it go in it's
like I said it in its own Anala tree is
a sharp because it will just not have
one main trunk but will have a multiple
shootings which means in turn that the
trunk there is a man-made thing thanks
to two hundred years of clipping of
these clippings so this also is a good
metaphor for a you know a legacy and an
alliance between men and in nature and
this is another part of why the olive
trees so looked upon you know it's kind
of a symbol of all the Western
civilization if we if we want to you
know a gigs and the Etruscans they
started to divide people between
civilized of barbarians whether they
were cultivating or not the other tree
and our and the grapevine sorry about
this and yet
this is not the only these are not the
only legacies that we are dealing with
while farming in Italy you know this is
all yellow but it wasn't so in the past
this is all green but it's not
necessarily gonna be gained in the
future you know it's kind of striking
this is three charts sorry three maps on
the skull aridity index I don't know if
my translation is good enough but anyway
is the combination of the amount of
water and the state of soils that we
have okay and this is 1950 and this is
62 the 90s and this is 71 to 2000 now my
farm is exactly here exactly on that
line between that yellow and the game
and that line wasn't there 40 years ago
[ __ ] sorry okay but anyway so what can
we do about all this okay what can we do
about this this is how we are managing
the farm today of course all the
different colors I have a meaning but
basically houses all the trees these are
the blue is where the animals are or
will you know those paddocks that are
mainly for animals are animals like
horses and cows basically and then we
have a few pigs the green is the
vegetable gardens or future oceans the
head is audible the yellow is those land
that can only be pastured even because
the boots or you know pastures and all
that kind of stuff so we are trying to
our concept is an ecological concept we
want to add as many items into elements
into our into our ecosystem so instead
of doing a monoculture of course we are
we're going to oh okay I'm sorry about
that add more elements to it of course
you can this is easy to eat for
buddy but this is kind of an outline of
all the studies going on in the farm
it's basically we're working basically
on four different levels one is farming
proper one is today's one is education
and one is nonprofit and I believe that
the sustainability of the whole farm
will come from the interaction of these
four different levels among themselves
hopefully one day but so what have we
done so far dealing with all these
legacies well it came easy I was lucky
enough that it came easy for me to start
with dealing with the olive trees I
didn't have a clue what an olive tree
was when I started I didn't have a clue
on how to donate I didn't have to clue
on how to harvest it and yet these guys
were still giving me one the best
product in the world I was happy I was
lucky enough to start traveling in this
part of the world and meeting with some
top-notch shares and they are the one
who I owe the fact that I recognize how
the value of this thing again in the
beginning you know you're in Italy and
everybody in Italy has an olive tree you
know you're the farmer and everybody is
farming olive trees so you think well
it's an olive tree you know and then you
start traveling New York City and you
got your product acknowledged and you
find out that simply by harvesting
something that is on your farm and
pressing you're doing something that is
unique it's not the best in the world in
terms that they might be potentially
other product that I just as good but
defend its it's amazing you know I just
have to go get it you know and and I
think we've gone up I've gone a bit far
mainly took me 15 years to understand
how to prune a tree but I'm finally
finding the way to put those back into
into action we found out we put in
action a few things like of course all
of our gloves have grass we are mulching
the clipping right on side instead of
burning
like everybody else is doing around us
honestly I don't understand why they
keep burning because it takes a lot of
more energy and a lot more you know time
and it's all kind of ongoing to feed the
greenhouse effect instead of key of
feeding the of feeding the feeding the
earth basically the ground I'm proud to
say that we have orchids in this orchard
because we never till you know and and
then again we harvest we prune and we
sell I'm happy to say that I was able to
reach again a few shares in new city
that buying for me a couple of the
biggest most famous restaurant in this
part of the world which of course is
helping me out if not directly done
under the economic point of view which
of course helps it helped me out because
I wouldn't be here today if it wasn't
for that you know it helped me out in
building you know something around it
this picture is also to remind that this
might also the whole thing might be a
risk climate is changing and the climate
change is going to affect the production
of our trees mmm particularly two ways I
mean milder climates until the winter
might inhibit the blossoms and
especially there's a the olive tree has
very peculiar water needs that I'm
basically coordinated so far with how
the season goals in terms of a we have
two peaks in the spring one into staying
one in the fall this long drought in the
sum and that's something that the olive
trees like as long as they have brains
in the fall or they have gains in that
particular moment in the in the in the
spring if that shifts then the whole
thing might be might be affected this is
particularly particularly true with
olive oil that is a peculiar substance I
like to be a producer of olive oil
because it's the only substance is the
only food that comes to the table after
being processed that is still alive
there's no heat no fermentation involved
in the making is just a squeezing which
means that the enzyme that are into the
alley when the olive is on the tree they
don't get killed during the processing
which is a blast because it's like I
mean figure that you're growing tomatoes
you will wish that all of your customer
could eat the tomato right out of divine
in the middle of the garden in August
that's what I do with my olive oil I can
do that even in New York 5,000 miles
away or six months later because this
keeps being fresh because again i don't
need to process it only to pasteurize
because there's no bacteria that can go
in it but the other side is that
anything that is into the oil is not
there because of me but it's there
because of my plants it might tell why
if my terror is changing because climate
is shifting I might not be able to do
that anymore just another picture just
briefly go to olive oil making this is
the sum of the olives getting into the
into the olive mill that picture is
taken tonight because again it's all a
matter of enzyme so we want to inhibit
certain enzyme to start working and
that's why we have missed during the day
and we press at night and and all that
um I have other things to say so I'm
going through and then maybe at the Q&A
if anybody has more question about it I
would be happy to to come to come back
at it but again this is to say that one
this is how we deal with one of the
legacies that we are dealing with online
on our farm I'm really happy I'm
grateful to be dealing with something
that made me famous in new CD and I just
found it there I just had to you know
pick it up put in in action in a way
that would be sustainable for for me and
and I have a great product that is
taking me you know all around word how
else
did we deal with these legacies how else
is that those legacies inspire what
we're doing today on the farm well
definitely the water tunnel was a great
inspiration again in the beginning I
didn't care about it you know it's just
a water tunnel you go in and they sealed
it but then you start realizing that a
you know this is not but now so I start
to and try to understand how is it
possible that something that was done
3,000 years ago is still giving us water
today and again there are a few keys to
the stability of it and again one key is
the passive functioning so it's led by
gravity another key to the functioning
of it is that it it it allows for water
exchanges all the way to the length of
the tunnel and the reason why you see
water coming out of it and you don't see
the water coming into it it's because
the water that is collected there is
basically there because of what we call
hidden rains we call he remains because
you don't see it but it's just basically
a condensation of micro quantities
Michael droplets of water that can get
condensed or could gather you know
microdroplets square inch multiply for
tens of meters or hundreds of meters of
length of a ton low end up in something
tangible so basically these two concept
you know water driven by gravity and the
combination of very small quantities x
very large numbers that are at the base
of of the function meant of the of the
water tunnel and based on these two
principles I was able to re-consider all
of the water management system on the
farm so now we have a little pump that
is operated by the Sun and a number of
containers that are you know this pole
that i'll put on different places and
different height of on the hill flag the
concept is that the PVE is operating a
pump that is the only pump that can go
straight in
pv system because it's a non-relative is
a piston pump that is hooked up directly
to the pv system and he's starting to
pump as soon as the Sun is out and it
will go on until the Sun is not there
anymore so this goes on and on and on
but of course the quantity per minute is
small but the minutes are a lot of them
so we can lift a lot of water every day
as long as we have somewhere to store it
but the somewhere to study again this is
I did my own sound but now me it wasn't
but not to me to put it in action that
the concept of storing water is a
concept that implies where do I store it
and what do I need for so we ended up
having five different containers right
now that I've get filled each is filled
every day and each is filled by the
overflow of the previous one and if
you're feeding each tank with the
overflow of the previous one it means
that you want to know in advance where
your water where you want your water to
be and what are you need so the first
tank is for portable use the second is
for drinking from the water for the
drinking water for the horses and the
animals and then we have three that are
feeding our gardens that I get different
heights this is one of my collaborator
checking on the quality of water I'm
sorry but I didn't have any other
picture of that of the of the tank and
then there are three things that are
feeding to our garden and then we adjust
it's not that we want to be something
that is stuck in the past we're using
modern technology but I like the fact
that this technology this way of using
modern technology was inspired by the
past because it's so more holistic again
the one choice of changing the pump has
lured me to have to invent where to put
the containers and the way the
containers are distributed along the
hill flank and all that and so I'm proud
to say that now we're running on zero
mission in terms of water management for
the gardens and and all the animals on
the farm lastly
how did we deal with these with the
legacy again we want to share so we
combined with the local county
government who is running the
Conservancy with the only farm who was
able to actually build a trail and is
open to the public anybody can come in
see our farm five days a week between
10am and one hour before the sunset this
is just open because we feel that a tomb
doesn't belong to us it belongs to
mankind you know we don't want to be
closed we want to be open and the same
time this is bringing people to the farm
which is good because we want people to
be there because you know so this is
just briefly something that we had to
build for the trail this is a staircase
that is parting partly held by trees we
had this these are the way we since part
of it is on the bedrock and parties on
the trees we had to invent this system
of letting that tree swing this was a
nightmare to design but it was so much
fun to build so I'm proud to say that
it's there now and it's free of access
also this is a piece of a shard of
pottery that was found on the farm this
is actually a doll you which is a big
base the Roman used to store wine or oil
so this there's a legacy in there
another way of leg of dealing with that
is we're hosting we are actually holding
archaeological excavation every year so
we're cleaning up with the help of a
community of people including the
government we are cleaning up a piece of
you know these are this is some of the
this is kind of amazing this is one of
the beds you can see the pillow and the
bed-leg it's kind of cool and when we're
hosting seminarian events on the farm
and and and so that's all the pilot was
inspired by the by the legacies but of
course you know where's the food coming
from you know these are all nice ideas
but these guys need to eat these guys
need to eat and these guys need to read
as well you know so there's there's more
than that the farm
I told you in terms of agricultural
production we have about 10 acres of
olive trees we have about 30 horses on
the farm we have eight cows we have a
few peaks for us we have a couple of
acres of gardens we are looking into
being more and more self-sufficient as
much as we can even because there's no
point in wanted to output on the market
some of your production if simply the
market is not able to pay for it you
know you know for you to me to make to
make money enough to make a living but
anyway this is just about if you will
know I mean grass grass can be gays
grazing can be considered an inter
copying the glass is also protecting
soil from soil erosion is you know
holding moist and water so of course the
cows and the horses are gazing into
completely different system because they
want is a poly gas think one is among
orgastic so one likes tall grass one
like the short grass one like that
grasses and the other one likes legumes
and and each of the two are able to
interrupt the cycle of the intestinal
parasite of the other so they can they
can actually help each other out this is
also to show how big our trees are right
now these are guys that were planted in
early 50s they're still fairly young in
terms of olive trees and still a tree
like this can provide a solid two
hundred and fifty two maybe 300 pounds
of our lives every year which is not bad
also where's the food here's some
zucchini zucchini is with the view they
grow happy you know and this is the
layout of the garden and what will be
the growth this is not actually there
yet but but the government is organized
in 20 different fields we actually have
a ten year rotation which might sound be
too complicated but it's okay because we
have artichokes and alfalfa in it that
are staying you know for the total of
almost five years so have a half of our
of our soil we don't really have to look
after
what are we doing ok we have we go in
the other way so we got our t-shirts for
two and a half year we chop the
artichoke off what we're doing is
actually we take these plants off after
they finish producing most part of
people they will leave it until October
in order for them to spring back so they
can take clones out of it what we're
doing we're just taking the whole plant
off and Transplant it you know and then
let it come and then we transplant in
the next field so we actually are able
to use this field in the summer for
brassicas or winter squash whatever is
still still available there and also
what we're doing then we got we got of
course the reason why we have 10 year
notation is because the bulk of our
summer crops is nightshades so we had to
twice the size for nightshades than for
the other families and that's why we
have tenure tation so that they come
basically back every every 5 and what
we're doing for especially for tomatoes
it works really well because these are
coming out of the alfalfa they do me but
for tomatoes what we're doing we are
planting the hairy vetch ahead of time
and then we just cut it and use it as a
mulch so we are transplanting on sod
instead of transplanting on till land
this is kind of important in our climate
because this allows us to anticipate the
tilling before the raining season
instead of after which is good because
that is saving us a lot of water then
we're doing letters then we're doing
zucchini and cumberland melons and then
we got the alfalfa so basically we have
a few fields that are in alpha alpha a
few fields that are in artichokes they
have this I perennial this is of course
a legume knows but we got let me lick
nose in here also with what we're doing
with planting subterranean clover
underneath the the the artichokes and
this is supposed to act as a perennial
and the same time I didn't get there yet
but the plan is to build a move all
chicken coop and gaze that the chickens
onto the clover and onto the alpha alpha
so that will even boost even more my
my nitrogen again I'm going to quickly
but then after if you want to I can I
can come come back to it this is part of
our another thing is that we have where
is it like here we got clover this is
not closer actually is rye grass or
something like that because we're coming
but anyway we got one species to species
three species in this in a year
sometimes even more you know in the same
field which is not bad and this is part
of the concept alternating you know
permanent crops with with with crops
that are mmm temporary we are getting
into starting out on ceilings this is
something that I'm fairly new at but we
are starting to save our own seeds of
course though I mean this has been hazy
it it's the picture it's not the climate
but you know these panels are looking
pretty happy to me in any case that it
kills that are getting in cabbages we
got this this is kind of a funny story
we had way too many cauliflower this
year not because we planted too many but
because each of them was 15 pounds we
couldn't eat it you know it's I call it
a Catholic Catholic family you know
garden you have to have 12 kids to go
through the whole thing but anyway so
this is some of the garlic we of course
two holes we alternate the Catholic and
the carrot and so there is some part of
this oh this is this is the young
tomatoes in a mulch and I think these
are the same guys but bigger so what
we're doing again here you see that the
clear soil but this is sought this is
not till so it can go through the summer
quite easily you know a nice continuous
struggle I have two employees and one of
them is an older guy and he said every
time there's something complain say hey
you know this is not the way of doing it
and I said okay i don't care i do it
this way in any case and then he said
hey you know there's no grass at all in
this guy there
thank you yes wonder why these are some
of the some of the artichokes again we
chop the whole thing off we try we
parted basically so that we can
concentrate the water we water is very
limiting factor in our climate so we
want to make the most of it and the same
time this is clearing the field so we
can we can put you know the cabbages in
earlier so it makes sense to me to have
a bit more work and these are the actual
finally going going in you can see the
claw that was planted about one month
one month before 12 months before and
just following the the season and these
guys are pretty healthy today I'm happy
about it this is one of the secret
weapons that we use for the garden some
of you might be familiar with it this is
a Spader this is the picture that I took
of it the day I bought it I bought it i
bought this from a neighbor who didn't
know what it was he used to have it in
his yard he was going to throw it away I
bought it by the pound and I was very
lucky and I was very happy this is the
waywards it's very it's kind of very
heavy piece of equipment it dates back
to nineteen seventy one and it still
working so that's sustainable also and
and above all it's I was kind of amazed
it's a picture that I took when i bought
it i mean with one strike it goes from
this to this which is wow I mean they
all discount it because you have to go
so slow but yeah I could go slow if that
dissolve especially the way chops
everything which is kind of big chunks
you know it's it's it's really good and
of course this is the other secret
weapon you know even here there's a lot
of work but it pays off you know so this
is manual ok we retail it under and we
yes we do kill but also you might want
to consider that with this we can just
back and just plow a little strip so
that might be minimum killing also you
know minimum tilling might be also to
just concentrate the tilling to where
you need and when you need it we're
running out of time so outcome I was
asked
several times if I think that organic
being an organic farmer would be more
different more difficult than being a
conventional farmer and I say no I think
it's a lot easier it just depends how
you measure your outcome if you're an
outcome is only making money then maybe
being a conventional farmer would be
easier but if you measure your outcome
in a need in a different way then you
might be in trouble if you're a
conventional farmer I measure my outcome
by trying to understand how much can I
be of help to other people we are having
roofers and interns and people that are
coming to help from all over the world
and we made at Percy's choice in terms
of entrepreneurship in organizing our
system on the farm that is a system that
requires a lot of hand labor and we had
to come up with the opening ourselves to
you know to new people that want to come
and help but the same time these people
that are coming in help they're coming
from all over the world and they stay
with us and they share and we can you
know live together and be happy together
and be you know having the feeling that
we are working jointly on something that
is a common goal no matter where we are
from and no matter what our life is is
to be you know not everybody is working
all the time but we are definitely
sharing knowledge we are sharing food
you know we are learning from each other
and that's a good outcome you know
especially because this doesn't clash
with the fact that I'm making money I'm
not making that much money but I can
stay in business and the same time
there's more than money also I want to
you know this is a picture of all ladies
back in the old days harvesting on it
and I like working the way I do not just
because not just because I don't just
want to remember about this but I want
to reproduce it if possible in a modern
key we are building a community and
that's part of our
of the part of my like this is the
picture of a calendar that we're putting
on sale here in the United States as a
fundraiser to sponsor scholarships for
students to come and work on the farm we
are willing to build up a community of
an ongoing community of students on the
farm with people from different
backgrounds we're shooting right now to
43 people at the time one out of farming
school one after culinary school one out
of her ballistic and natural path
because I believe that knowledge is
holistic I believe that it would be a
great experience for somebody just out
of school to stay six months or one year
in a different country working on
something that is specific and yet being
exposed to somebody that has a similar
background that is you know limited
Falls to what he or she is doing I would
love to do so to do something like that
but also I'm practical you know and
being practical I acknowledge that
there's always so much that I don't know
about the farm you know and that I
should now so I think that the most
valuable tool for my farm will be
something that will always be spending
nights on books in order to know more
about it because you know yeah I know
some about it but there's still a lot
more so this is a game when page of the
calendar the concept is that we have
chefs for each page which pages 11
picture that is telling you something
about the olive oil production but also
is one chefs telling you what to do with
it and this is why I call this a
community building because it is that
all share in the united states that are
buying from acidy value willing to
support us in something that is actually
supporting american students to come
over to the farm it's a cycle you know
that's the part I like and that's the
part I like because basically we're all
united with all one thing you know with
all fractals into a larger picture most
of us don't are able are not able to see
the larger picture and are only focusing
on what they're doing but I'm sorry
that's not way to go you know we all
connected you know and we want to remind
us that man was able to participate in
the you know both in the miracle of
turning the Gallo into green
in which we are still able to do we a
lot better in turning the green into
into into into yellow and that's that's
something that we want to be very
careful of but no matter what this is
all connected okay so this is not an
outcome this is a little plan like this
they took out of my garden the rules I
coming all the way like this which I
take it as a good sign that my soil is
doing well I mean organic matter is two
point 69 now it's okay yay it was 145
years before so that's good okay I like
that I like this I like this guy to be
there this is fan club taking a breath
but the same time this is more than fine
q because it's these guys that are going
to hold on for this line everything goes
to the you know organic matter and the
fertility of soil that is able to retain
water basically you know at the same
time we don't want to we want to
remember what good acid mankind we were
able to do in the past and the bad this
is a picture I took in the eocene Uzbek
it does in Central Asia this is the
biggest man-made disaster in terms of
water management it was just
unbelievable to be there and again we
want to remember all that has been going
through in the passing years and every
time I look at those trees and that's
why I call it a challenge to be a farmer
in Italy because every time I look at
those trees I can't picture the 3,000
years of history that made it possible
for those streets to be there today and
I start wondering what are we doing
today for somebody that would be here in
three thousand years from now now you
don't want to answer that question
because honestly we're just [ __ ] the
whole thing up so basically I'm just
every time I look at this landscape I'm
just wondering am i doing the right
thing every time I'm desilting the water
tunnel are we doing the right thing I
guess I am I'm pretty sure that I'm
doing that I think in calling over
people from the world over all over the
world and share what I'm doing and share
what I have in order to find out what
the boss best possible
outcome will be how to measure it
monuments we can't eat the olive trees
we can eat and also is way of
remembering the way mankind has been
able to be respectful to this planet and
this is valid Allah this is in town the
golden valet everybody's looking for
gold the goal is Tomatoes the gold is
producing something that is able to feed
us and again I can't but take the water
tunnel as a metaphor for I'm going to
burst for you know what good man has
done and hopefully we'll be able to
reproduce this in the future thank
okay okay yeah I was wondering what I
was okay okay yeah yes we don't we don't
we don't irrigate and we might do so if
climate change but even so we wouldn't
do it in the summer because in the sum
of the olive tree needs to have at least
a solid month to two months of drought
in order to create the antioxidants if
it's if it's done in the wrong in the
wrong period of time it would yes there
are stories of farmers that spend huge
amount of money in order to create
irrigation line from the olive trees and
that water is just water so when you
squeeze the oil the water goes down to
drain and actually does bad because the
antioxidant I water-soluble modern I
they are lipo soluble so love all of the
antioxidant will go with the water so
you want to be careful in irrigated
olive trees they need water in this in
the spring they will need water in the
fall but they will not need water in
that in the in the summer so you can use
it once you plant your trees because you
want to boost the growth in the first
years but once you get into production
you want to be you want to be careful
with that yeah
no for that folder for the most part our
orchard the long story short the bulk of
our trees were planted in early 50s and
they were planted in combination with
bind with gay binds so our trees are
very much space paste apart so there's a
lot because the gate one was ripped off
the ground back in the 70s for subsidies
that pay farmers not to be farmers
anymore or something like that and so we
have a lot of space so all of our
gardens are embedded into into the part
of the olive groves and some of our
fields are as well but this is very very
common concept I mean there's a text in
the 1600 in Italy that already talks
about intercropping you know trees with
with other type of cropping so i don't i
don't think i don't think there is
anything wrong with it except for the
fact that for example this is this
doesn't let us do mechanical harvesting
of the trees because we can't access the
tractor you know into the government's
you know so we have to go with handmade
harvest which of course requires a lot
of work there are a few tools and you
know that can help with that but still
is a lot of a lot of work and you need a
lot of labor to do so and that's
basically one of the main problem with
the bulk of the girls today especially
in Italy that they were planted in sand
and laid out maybe even only 50 years
ago like in this case which is nothing
but they were laid out and design in a
moment in which nobody would think about
harvested harvesting mechanically so
we're not sustainable in on the market
because our cost of production in Italy
is seven noodles a leader a leader is a
portable gallon if you go in Spain which
is still Europe that drops two three if
you go to Tunisia that drops to I don't
know what because of cost of labor and
that's why a lot of people are ripping
off ending up with leaping off the grove
and this is kind of a you know
a disaster because they're reaping all
of those girls that are more prone to be
taped off at the one that I actually
stronghold against climate change only
tree is a very peculiar thing in fact it
can it can grow in a pile of rocks and
you can grow and bear fruit with less
than 400 millimeters of rain per year so
has been used by mankind as a conquering
plant in order to you know switch from
that yellow into green that was a key
factor the olive tree and now we've got
into the to the other to the other end
which people are reaping those plants
off only because they cannot make a
living sounds like [ __ ] to me I mean
we call this progress but honestly I
don't know you know so I know if there
are any more questions or if lunch is
calling no yeah
no I didn't I didn't have I didn't plan
any any more trees again the bulk of my
trees are about I did is called kanino
which is a local variety that takes the
names of the next town over so it's kind
of a heirloom local variety that was
used for ever and it's very hardly you
know and it is very it fits very well
that environment and those were the one
that we planted in the early 50s then
when in the 70s they took the vines off
there are two parts of the farm in which
the ground is so shallow that you
wouldn't be able to do anything else and
so they planted more planting there they
you know in in between and those are two
different buyers from touring the chino
which are very productive and very
common but both of them are very early
in the season so being early in our
climate means that they're very prone to
the attack of a parasite that is the
diali fly so it's kind of likely that we
wouldn't be able to have as much of
those trees today but I don't plan to I
don't I don't plan to add more trees
right now I don't play I don't know if I
will ever do in the future because there
are so many different or child around us
that are kind of neglected because
people don't know how to make a living
with it anymore because the long story
short is all the trees has always been
planted in small batches you know
they're only to support the family you
know so the goggle number of places
around me that have maybe ten threes
2339 never big enough in order to make a
living today they used to represent you
know wealth back in the old days but
nowadays it's just lost so I know if you
in the picture with all these the farm
with all the different colors the colors
were kind of getting out of the farm
limits because we are starting to t mean
with neighbors you know because we are
lucky to be you know able to sell our
crop and so a better team in more
farmers or team in more trees instead of
planting more than my on my own grounds
you know item I don't think it will make
sense to start new girls when we have
all ones that are
dying yep
ah no not yet my so sex is not that big
yet okay and no there are a lot of
people that are looking at what I'm
doing with great interest for sure and
because i'm unable to sell my product
ahead of time almost every year we sell
out we sell out with the price that is
almost twice as much as the common
market price for the same or equivalent
product of course i'm trying to do my
best you know that for my pillar to
stand up of course but you know it's not
said that other people couldn't do the
same you know my and we're doing this by
cutting the cost of production in terms
of money because we're using volunteer
workers so it's not that we are not
paying them of course we're paying in a
different currency that's part of how we
stay in business is because we are
working in these two two different
currencies one is cash and one is giving
away what we have which is meat which is
good food which is landscape which is
being in Italy which is our knowledge
which is you know sharing what we have
and what we know which is something that
we're very each of now has this come to
the point where other farmers aren't me
are willing to team in with me just for
that not yet part of it is also a
generational problem you know I'm 40 I
just turned 40 few days ago and I I'm
being on on that farm managing that fun
15 years I'm a newbie in a country you
know that these kind of conservative
farmers that have been there for 700
generation you know and oh you know this
is the way to do it because my father
used to do it and my grandfather used to
do it and what do you know I don't know
okay you keep going and I keep going my
way and then you cannot you know again
how do you measure your outcome you know
I'm not unhappy or what I'm doing but I
can't just be forcing other people to do
it because it's a matter of philosophy
basically you know hopefully one day
maybe my business my success
so big that my economic success will
overpower the differences in philosophy
but you know that's not my main
occupation right now my main equation is
trying to stay in business and and and
and run a farm not just be a sociologist
for now that may be for the future I
don't know yeah yeah
now say that the game yeah yeah so I
guess the question is is there any
evidence at least on your farm oh that
there is plenty of evidence not on my
farm but there is plenty of evidence
that the water tunnels that i'm talking
about of Etruscan origin are at the base
of the Roman aqueducts okay it's exactly
the same concept is the same technology
all of what we know about the human and
we know of as Roman hydraulic technology
is actually has been invented by the
Etruscans and it was pockets of
intelligentsia of the Etruscan people
into the Roman society that was still
managing those the only invention into
important invention in terms of
hydraulic technology into the Roman time
is the reverse siphon that came much
later so the principle is exactly the
same is also these underground is also
this horizontal structure linear
structure that God began bigger and the
only thing that the Romans actually did
is couple those with the ark but the
building of the ark the arch and and so
and the other difference is is basically
difference in the society so all the
tunnels into the Etruscan society with
feeding small communities because it was
a society that was very spread out while
the Roman power of course was Center
power that was able and had the need to
lay out and had built these huge works
that of course went on as long as the
center power was able to defend and and
maintain it and then of course they
collapse up that but there's absolutely
a continuity between in the two and the
two technologies the main difference in
terms of water is that the water tunnels
are the water the walls are unlined so
the water can seep you know so
the walls and so there is what exchanges
between the inside of the tunnel and the
underground versus an aqueduct this is
only made to transport water so we'll
have the walls lined with waterproof
plaster that will retain water but it's
exactly exactly the same thing
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu